In the last video I challenged
you to write multiple Fibonacci
functions, ones that
could calculate the nth
term of the Fibonacci
sequence either iteratively
or recursively.
And I'll do the first
shot right over here.
And I'll show you over
the next few videos
that there's really multiple
ways of even doing this just
iteratively.
So let's define our
function, Fibonacci.
And it has a
parameter n, so that
is what we're going to
pass to the function.
And we know that by
definition, the first two
terms of the Fibonacci
sequence are 0 and 1.
So let's make a
list for ourselves.
And so this is interesting.
So this is the first
time we're really
going to do some
of the actual list
manipulation in this video.
So the terms here-- the 0th term
of the Fibonacci sequence is 0.
And the first 1 is 1.
This is by definition.
So we're just going to kind of
hard code that in right there.
And then what we're
going to do is
if we're then going to
construct this list to all
of the terms up to and
including the nth term,
and then return the nth
term from that list.
And the reason why I'm
going to do it this way
is it's able to save up kind of
a memory of all the Fibonacci
numbers, which is
helpful for computing
each incremental
Fibonacci number.
So let's do it this way.
I'm going to use a while loop.
You could do it
using a for loop,
but for me a while loop feels
a little bit more natural
for this.
And actually before I even
define the while loop,
I'm going to set my
variable of iteration.
I'm going to set
that equal to 0,
and you're going to see
how this works in a second.
So I'm going to say while i
is less than or equal to n.
So i is going to start at
0, and then go up to n.
And actually frankly,
i shouldn't start at 0
because we already have the 0th
term here and the first term
here.
And we want to construct
the second, third, fourth,
all the way to the nth term.
So actually, let's start i at 2.
So we already have the 0th
term and the first term.
We then want to construct
the second term.
So that's why we're going
to start i equals 2,
all the way up to and
including the nth term.
So that's why we say
less than or equal to n.
We're going to keep adding
terms to this sequence.
So while i is less
than or equal to n,
I'm going to take this list
right here, and to the end
of that list-- and this
is a built-in function
for any list in Python,
and you're learning it now.
And you can look it
up, and actually my IDE
tells me how to use it-- I can
add to the end of that list
another term.
And that next term I'm going
to add to the end of the list
is going to be the sum of
the previous two terms.
So it's going to
be, terms i minus 1.
So that's the previous term.
Terms i minus 1 literally
refers to the previous term.
i minus 1 plus terms i minus 2.
So this is essentially going
to construct this Fibonacci
sequence and build
it in this list.
And then we're going
to increment i.
i is equal to i plus 1.
If we never increment
i, then this loop
will just keep going
on forever and ever.
But this way it's
going to keep going up
and up and up until
at some point i
is not going to be less
than or equal to n,
and then we're going to
break out of the loop.
And then when we break
out of the loop--
let me do it right over--
when we break out of the loop,
we can then return the nth
Fibonacci term in the sequence.
So we're going to return terms.
We're going to return
the nth term in terms.
So let's see if this works.
Let's see, does this make sense?
So I'm going to go all the
way up to the nth term,
and actually the nth term
here-- yes, this should work.
Because if this
was Fibonacci of 0,
I want to return terms of 0,
which is this term right here.
If it's Fibonacci
of 1, I would want
to return this term
right over here.
So the first term in terms.
Not the 0th, but the first.
So this feels like
it should work.
And actually even
before I run it,
I want you to make
sure you understand
what I've done
here with the list.
So I'm going to show you a
little bit an example of how
these lists work.
So if I define a list as,
I don't know, 1 comma 2.
That's my list.
And if I then say-- it's
doing something weird.
So I'm going to define
my list as 1 comma 2.
So if I type a, it's 1 comma 2.
If I append to a, a dot append.
So if I append a, let's
say I append a 7 to it.
Then if I look at a, I
have a 7 at the end of it.
If I want to refer to
the elements here, a of 0
should be the first element.
a, the second element, I just
put the 2 in the brackets
and it should give me the 7.
So that's exactly what
I'm doing over here.
I'm saying terms of i minus 1.
So we're going to add
a new term over here.
So this first time
it goes to loop,
we're going to add a new term.
And it's going to be the
sum of terms of i minus 1.
So in that first loop,
i is 2. i minus 1 is 1.
So terms of 1 plus terms of 0.
So it's going to be terms of
1 which is 1, plus terms of 0.
And then it keeps doing
that all the way until we
construct the nth term.
Well enough talk, and I'll step
through it a little bit clearer
in the next video with
a particular example.
But let's just see if what
we wrote actually works.
So let me run it.
All right.
And let's see if we get the
proper results Fibonacci--
well, let's just start from
the beginning-- Fibonacci of 0.
Well, that looks good.
Let's try Fibonacci of 1.
That looks good.
Fibonacci of 2.
This should also be 1.
That looks good.
Fibonacci of 3--
this should be 2 now,
because we're seeking
the sum of 1 plus 1.
That works.
Let's try the Fibonacci of 10.
Hey, that looks pretty good.
Let's try the Fibonacci
of something huge.
Fibonacci of 100.
Well, this gets a little bit--
I won't go into the-- well,
this is a very large
number, and I'm not
going to go into
the whole floating
kind of the long numbers
and the super large ones.
But let's try something a
little bit smaller here.
So let's try Fibonacci of 20.
So it looks like it works, and
you can verify it for yourself.
So this is just one
implementation of it,
and in the next few
videos, I'm going
to try another way
to implement it.
Maybe I'll do it
with a for loop,
or we can also do
it recursively.